il ya eu la signature du jumelage samedi
à les anses d'arlet entre la ville de
ouidah et celle des anses d'arlet nous
avons voulu élargir le champ jumelage à
la communauté d'agglomération de
l'espace sud et ces deux là aujourd'hui
que nous avons signé une convention de
partenariat avec une association de
communes de l'atlantique et du littoral
du bénin akale alors nous avons établi
autour de ce projet des priorités pour
les notamment ceux qui concernent la
jeunesse et c'est de là qu'ils nous
avons déjà sélectionné un groupe de six
jeunes volontaires qui partiront bientôt
sur le bébé et les actions seront menées
dans pratiquement plusieurs activités
notamment sur lyon c'est la pêche
l'agriculture d échanger avec des
étudiants du tourisme mémoriel vont
enfin nous sommes là il y aura il ya un
comité technique a été mis en place
il y avait un comité de pilotage on
devait réunir bientôt et définir les
priorités parce que des idées y en a
près le pont et des tables et le pont et
tracer ces derniers établi alors là
aujourd'hui il nous faut nous approprier
il nous faut nous a beau briller et
cette opportunité d'aller parce que
d'aller au bénin d'aller et en afrique
1 parce qu'il ya tout petit il y a
beaucoup de potentialités à ce niveau et
puis diot aussi qu' il ya eu beaucoup de
paroles
il ya eu beaucoup d crif mais il ya eu
très peu dette et là aux anses d'arlet
nous sommes disposés à agir et le sud de
la martinique et dispose
régime alors sur mon souhait c'est que
toute la martinique réalise le reconnaît
directement à l'ouverture que prône
aussi le béninois vers davantage commune
de matinée oui c'est à dire les béninois
sont arriveront en point certain nombre
de le contacter puisque il voudrait même
s'il n'ya pas je me lâche tout de suite
un fils d'odin du bénin et est une ville
de martinique tout de suite puisque aux
anses d'arlet nous l'avons quand même
préparé pendant un an et demi
mais les maires du bénin qui sont ici on
vous veut le mettre en place des
partenariats ben les partenariats
c'est à dire au titre de la coopération
décentralisée alors là nous avons un
certain nombre de contacts ont été pris
et sinon au sur un avis favorable
alors il faut attendre on va travailler
on va les aider
on va on va aider toutes ces communes à
mettre en place ce partenariat avec la
coopération avec les villes des villes
du bénin